[Música]
spectrum madres adolescentes después de
tres años el padre de mi bebé todavía es
parte de nuestras vidas
321 ya
creo que la última vez yo estaba por
allá todo ha cambiado salí embarazada de
mi novio cuando teníamos 14 años después
de hacerse la prueba de paternidad la
corté introdujo visitas ella tenía diez
meses perdón ella tenía diez meses y
finalmente conoció a su papá y
las visitas duraron un tiempo pero se ha
estado metiendo en peleas y a este punto
prefiero hacerlo sola que con el antes
era muy duro y ahora todo cambió
completamente ambos hemos sido capaces
de superarlo todo había muchas cosas que
superar y tuve que soltar mucho dolor
que sentía y que afectaba mucho la copa
eternidad porque con esto no se trata de
lo que te hicieron se trata de criar un
hijo juntos y él asumió su papel es un
padre increíble estoy muy agradecida si
mi novia está muy involucrado en la vida
de nuestra hija estoy muy orgullosa de
cómo ha crecido como padre porque no
estaba preparado en absoluto tomo mucho
tiempo y paciencia con
con él y ella para hacer crecer ese
vínculo
ahora él está estudiando pero sigue
siendo impresionante saber que es capaz
de cuidar de ella las relaciones cambian
después de tener un hijo
321 ya
si en cuanto a la amistad es muy difícil
mantener las amistades que tenías antes
de ser madre y ser capaz de salir y
pasar el rato con los amigos pero tengo
amigas que me acompañaron durante el
embarazo y el parto y éstas ahora son
sus días mis amistades todas las
relaciones fueron positivas o negativas
ninguna se mantuvo la relación con mi
esposo se ha fortalecido desde el último
vídeo sinceramente los dos hemos
madurado emocionalmente mucho nos hemos
acercado con mis padres y los suyos
porque siento que cuando empezamos
nuestra relación estábamos como no
quiero ir a ver a mi mamá pero ahora
todo lo que queremos hacer es estar con
nuestras madres llore de inmediato por
mi mamá y por lo mal que la trate antes
de tener a mi hija y lloré por mi
hermana por como la trate por las
maestras y todas esas cosas que nos
dijeron tras tener un hijo todo cambia
si mi punto de vista sobre las
relaciones al igual que dije en el
primer vídeo cambio sobre todo cuando me
vi obligada a ser una joven madre
soltera y perdí a todo el mundo incluso
a mi familia por un tiempo pero gracias
a dios todos ellos volvieron vivi una
soledad total así que veo las relaciones
como un gran compromiso algo en lo que
dos personas se dicen estoy dispuesta a
estar contigo y tú estás dispuesto
quiero tener más hijos tres dos uno ya
está bien me sorprende que hayan dicho
que si en el último vídeo tenía creo que
un mes de ser mamá tenía un recién
nacido cinco meses después quedé
embarazada de nuevo así fue planificado
no tenemos muchos bebés en nuestra
familia y no quería que él creciera solo
y ahora mismo estoy ligeramente de
acuerdo porque dos son mucho me da miedo
tener más no quiero planificar el
siguiente con el tiempo sí que quiero
tener hijos no a corto plazo porque
todavía estoy intentando sacar la
carrera y mi novio está en la facultad
de derecho aunque estoy emocionada por
tener hijos una parte de mí está como
cielos debes pasar por la fase de bebé
otra vez pero sé que será más fácil
siendo mayor y más estable me emociona
pero una vez que llegue a los 4 años voy
a estar extrañando cuando ella no tenía
una opinión sobre nada porque fue un
buen momento estoy extremadamente de
acuerdo
me gustaría adoptar tenemos a cientos de
niños de todas las edades y verlos
corriendo creo que los niños son tan
increíbles y tan buenos para enseñarte
cosas que no sabías que necesitabas
aprender siento que dios estará enviando
mi niña cuál es tu número predilecto
tengo curiosidad es más te guía 3 el 7
es mi número previo de noal y el del
número perfecto si tendremos un autobús
escolar lleno de muñoz e a diario me
encanta es hora que sé lo que es estar
sola ser madre y no vivir en casa de mi
mamá es pesado y si quiero tener más
hijos pero una vez que beverly crezca
quiero que mis otros hijos crezcan
también para tener tiempo de ser yo
misma y separarme un poco de ser madre
seguiré siendo su mamá obviamente y
seguiría hablando con ellos después de
que cumplan 18 años así sigo teniendo
hijos siento que nunca voy a aprender
quién soy realmente tener un hijo fue
una enorme carga financiera 3
uno ya
mi situación es diferente porque me
dedico a youtube así es como género
dinero también hago otras cosas pero
youtube es la principal y sin ella no
habría tenido este espacio no habría
encontrado un lugar en donde pudiera
inspirar a otras madres pero también al
mismo tiempo tratar de prevenir el
embarazo adolescente porque antes de
quedar embarazada no sabía qué hacer
estaba deprimida estaba mal siento que
fui bendecida con la oportunidad de
poder planificarlo y tener algunos
ahorros así que no fue una carga para mi
esposo y yo aprendimos a hacer un
presupuesto aprendimos a invertir pero
detrás en nuestras espaldas escuchábamos
cosas como una mamá adolescente sin
dinero inmediatamente lo relacionaban
saben el mayor gasto de cuidado infantil
que tuve que pagar es decir muchos no se
dan cuenta que cuidar a sus hijos es
costoso están los estudios el trabajo
cosas que podría y quiero hacer pero que
no hago porque no puedo ya que estoy con
mi hija todo el tiempo así que tengo que
ser muy flexible en lo que puedo hacer
con ella estoy muy contenta de hacerlo
pero ir a juicio con su papá es lo más
costoso que he pasado en mi vida y por
lo que me endeudé y nadie habla de eso
si vas a tener un hijo hay gastos
extraños que aparecerán cuando mi hija
nació no tuve muchos gastos porque tuve
la bendición de ser capaz de amamantar
la creo que uno de los mayores costos
cuando tienes un recién nacido es lo
cara que es la leche de fórmula creo que
nunca sentí la carga financiera hasta
que tuve que ir a trabajar y ella tuvo
que ir a la escuela es una carga
económica porque necesito que alguien la
cuide no tengo familia mi novia está
estudiando muchas madres reciben un
sueldo y casi la mayor parte va
directamente a la guardería
es como porque estoy trabajando si todo
va la guardería pero al mismo tiempo
necesitas el dinero que queda si me
preocupa no ser una buena madre
321 ya
vaya tú puedes
y creo que depende de cómo definas ser
una buena madre cuando se trata de eso
creo que es alguien que ama a su hijo y
hace todo lo posible para apoyarlo hay
momentos en los que me preocupo porque
si los grite mucho hoy o algo así pero
al final quiero a mi hijo y creo que eso
es lo que defina una buena madre
pensando en sus padres intentan imitar a
sus padres cuando crían a sus hijos o
huyen de esa idea
personalmente huyo de ello porque fue
mucha la disciplina física al crecer y
fue agotador mentalmente siento que la
prioridad de mis padres era ser buena en
la escuela tuve comida a una casa y fui
bien
atendida porque cubrieron mis
necesidades pero siento que las
emociones deberían añadirse a esta
categoría no solo la comida el agua y el
techo mis padres eran buenos y eran muy
cariñosos pero
sus prioridades como padres eran muy
diferentes creo que la antigua forma de
pensar era que si tus hijos seguían las
reglas entonces eras bueno los adultos
exitosos no son los que siguen las
reglas son personas que piensan de forma
diferente y toman buenas decisiones
porque son las correctas no porque todo
el mundo les observa la forma de pensar
de entonces era diferente y hacían lo
mejor que podían y los quiero mucho pero
intento hacerlo diferente
tener un bebé cambio mi vida para mejor
321 ya
antes de tener a mi hija pensaba en lo
que iba a decir mi nota de suicidio no
estaba en un buen momento
ella me salvó la vida y no sólo mejoró
sino que me salvó porque tenía una razón
para seguir viva y trabajar en mí misma
para convertirme en una mejor persona y
sanar desde entonces mi vida se ha
vuelto tan increíble en formas que nunca
imaginé posibles gracias a ser madre ya
no es solo hacer las cosas por mí misma
claro no puedo compararme con usted está
aún porque no tengo mi bebé pero es tan
simple como levantarme para ir a mi
clase yo tengo una mayor motivación para
hacer cosas simples como esta y luchar
por algo mejor si por supuesto nunca
planee su llegada pero cuando me enteré
de que estaba embarazada y una vez que
lo tuve sentí una cantidad insuperable
de alegría y amor que de repente te
llena el corazón ser joven y tener un
hijo como que hay desafíos que vienen
con eso pero cuando miras el panorama
general de las cosas somos capaces de
amarlos y apoyarlos y de hacer que estos
pequeños seres humano maravillosos veo
mi vida en ese entonces y era bastante
fría con los bebés y con las personas
que me rodeaban y realmente no diría te
quiero tanto y ahora estoy como
agarrando las mejillas y abrazando a
cada persona que tengo la oportunidad de
abrazar porque la vida es corta y te das
cuenta de eso cuando tienes bebés porque
estábamos hablando de lo mucho que han
crecido desde el último vídeo y me rompe
el corazón que solo van a seguir
creciendo es imposible poner pausa
lindos donde el bebé
esta es la realidad
bien quiero abrazos los de todas